here's what I don't understand like you
always what don't you understand well
you've always wanted to make movies
right that's we know that well I mean
for the most part since you started
making movies you wanted to continue
making movies now what's hard for me to
wrap my head around is it's such a
daunting task to make a movie let alone
a successful movie
but then you're getting you're doing all
these things Guardians one is a huge
success Guardians two is a huge success
Suicide Squad Peacemaker all these
things and then someone's over at DC
says hey we want you to run the studio
yeah what would make someone first of
all did you think about saying no that's
not what I want to do and almost say no
when it first came up I was like
and it didn't come up nobody came to me
and said do you want to run DC but it
came to me very early in the process
would that be something you would be
interested in this is very early and I
was like nah I don't think so and the
the reasons were because it was me and
it wasn't me and Peter
um what made it appealing to me
eventually was because I also went to
Peter early on and he was like same way
but what eventually became appealing to
me was doing it with Peter so Peter
Safran has been
he's been my manager since I first moved
to LA when he was back when he was the
president of Bilstein Gray
we're very close friends we've traveled
together we hang out with our families
together we're you know uh close friends
and we've gotten maybe one or two
arguments over the past 25 years
um of working together
we work together exceptionally well we
never step on each other's toes I
respect his opinion completely about
many things and he you know he respects
my opinion about creative stuff
and so when it came to us as us as a
pair and basically Peter sort of
managing everything working as a
producer and me basically working as a
director directing the creative aspects
of things that became a different story
that became suddenly an opportunity to
do something that had never been done
before to create the biggest Story Ever
Told across you know film television
gaming and more
um and to to Really create a cohesive
you know DC Universe
um I also knew that there was going to
be many challenges as we embarked on
that Journey because
um people have different ideas about how
things are supposed to be people have
all sorts of things that they love
whether they love things from you know
um you know the dceu or they love things
from the arrowverse they love things
from the animated worlds or whatever
that is something that we knew was going
to be a ring of fire we were gonna have
to walk through and you knew you were
going to be
loved and hated at the same time
um because there's always people out
there I knew
I've been used to being loved and hated
for a long time like you know this is
I'm on Twitter you know
um that's what Twitter is it's love and
hate you know Twitter is like the the
prisoner with the Love on one hand and
hate on the other and just punching you
in the face with both sides yeah uh
but uh I knew that it was I was gonna
knew there was gonna be a period of
hardship you know and I knew that there
had been a spectacular uh missteps in
the past with all sorts of different
choices good answer uh but I'm thinking
you know were you thinking it to be the
head of DC was this gonna hinder me from
continuing my filmmaking and being so
you know having all that passion into
one Focus as opposed to now I'm gonna
direct a movie but I also have to worry
about running a studio how do we do that
yeah I mean I think that kind of helps
that out because he's Peter helps that
out I think that it's always been you
know I only have so much time in my day
I only have so much I can do and I think
it was always a question about how much
am I going to spend on writing how much
am I going to spend on directing how
much am I going to spend you know
ushering other writers how much am I
going to spend ushering other directors
how much am I going to spend mapping out
you know sort of a story that other
writers can follow there's like I I only
have so much I can do I'm aware of that
um and uh and so yeah it did and I love
directing so it's I didn't want to lose
that either
um but in my heart I'm a Storyteller in
my heart I am I am not the same as other
filmmakers I don't think some other
filmmakers for sure but in my heart I
consider myself a Storyteller I don't
consider myself a director over being a
Storyteller I'm a Storyteller first and
that means whatever way I'm able to tell
that story I'm okay I have this
conversation with Dave yarva the
director of brightburn is one of my best
because he wants to direct movies like
he's mostly interested in directing
movies that's what he wants to do I'm
like I I you know if I can tell a great
TV story that is like doing Peacemaker
was absolutely great for me you know
doing a movie is absolutely great like
if I'm proud of what I'm putting out I'm
really happy it doesn't really matter to
me what that story is you know I started
out I wanted to write comic books when I
was younger if I was writing comic books
today I'd probably be I'd probably be
unhappy because you know so few people
are writing or reading comic books
um but I would probably be uh you know
really you know happy with what my job
was I'd enjoy that storytelling process